G1
[Música]
o número marcado pela pandemia da couve
19 anos muitas foram as questões
levantadas sobre a confiança dos
portugueses nas notícias que os
jornalistas como eu faço e fazemos a
e essa confiança Apesar tudo e apesar de
daquilo que podemos achar a confiança
aumentou quatro pontos percentuais em
relação ao ano passado o ano passado se
vamos nos 56 por cento e este ano cinco
anos nos 61 por cento houve um
crescimento de 4 por cento em relação ao
ano passado de confiança de vocês para
nós Jornalistas do trabalho que nós
fazemos
ouvir Este estudo feito pela rotas
Instituto mostra exatamente o gráfico
que eu te trago aqui em que o topo da
tabela em como marca de comunicação
social em que os portugueses mais
Confiam 81 e meio por cento da RTP
contrastante com o Correio da Manhã
51 e meio por cento
e este esta Este estudo a que
estudou passa redundância 44 países a
Deus nos deu nos a percepção que a média
deste da confiança dos cidadãos destes
países que a média situava-se nos 46 por
cento ou seja Portugal está bastante
acima com 61 por cento está bastante
Acima da Média destes 44 países
nós temos uma questão que este estudo
que eu estrago
também retrata e é um uma questão que
nos via preocupar a todos não são os
jornalistas como a vocês que público são
as fake News as notícias falsas ou a
desinformação muitos de nós certamente
que já Enquanto fazemos de cor ao nosso
telemóvel as nossas redes sociais
deparamos com notícias falsas notícias
kerecem obviamente de informação seja no
Instagram no Twitter no telegram no no
WhatsApp o Facebook e foi feito uma
pergunta aos inquiridos se preocupe me o
que é real e falso na internet vemos que
as percentagens de concordo de um ano
para o outro do ano passado para este
ano ou Que Se alteraram mas é um ponto
importante E que é bastante
preocupante que o ponto azul claro que o
discordo que como vemos praticamente
e as pessoas que se que se importam se
estão ou não a ler notícias falsas estão
se completamente a marimbar-se o que
estão a ver no Facebook é verdadeiro ou
falso
bom e isso traz a obviamente
questões que nós temos que ter
presentes na nossa mente e só se combate
Na minha opinião as notícias falsas as
informação com dois pontos uma é a vossa
responsabilidade enquanto leitores
telespectadores e ouvintes
em saber se tracionar exatamente onde
vão buscar informação e quem é que
escreve a informação que quem que fala a
informação que vocês estão ouvir isso é
bastante importante feito por vocês
relacionarem bem as fontes de informação
mas obviamente que nós jornalistas temos
um papel a fundamental em sermos ainda
mais rigorosos em sermos ainda mais
cinzentos e levarmos a realidade ao
expoente máximo da nossa missão enquanto
os jornalistas
digo isto a
recordo uma fotografia que tirar em 2017
é isto para falar sobre a importância e
em 2017 tirei uma fotografia do nosso
Presidente da República Marcelo pelo
Souza dentro de um carro abraçar um
senhor tinha perdido tudo nos incêndios
de outubro não senhor completamente a
chorar copiosamente e essa fotografia
correu redes sociais correuos jornaes
correu televisões e isso é exatamente aí
que está o ponto da importância do
fotojornalismo e do jornalismo que é a
achar
sensibilidades ou seja vocês muitas
pessoas como vocês souberam a partir
desse momento o que estava realmente a
passar-se e o que se passou exatamente
naquele sítio que é que o homem perdeu
tudo com aquele homem perdeu tudo outras
pessoas tantas perderam tudo nos
incêndios no entanto hoje vim aqui falar
sobre o meu trabalho na premia a
eu estive durante este último ano e meio
não tive um único dia confinado eu
estive todos os dias desde a pandemia
cobrirá para mim a fora de casa e a
minha atenção enquanto fotos na lista
foi ter sido os vossos olhos vocês que
estiveram em casa entre trabalho em tela
a escola não puderam sair de casa sair é
um para saídas
altamente
indispensáveis não é para ir às compras
virar a farmácia seja o que for não
saíram de casa uma série tempo e tal
como eu outro fotos realistas saímos
para ser os vossos olhos e essa a
intenção quando nós fazemos o nosso
trabalho é mostrar a realidade muitas
vezes dela muitas vezes ela é dura e
difícil dizer com muitas imagens que
aqui vos mostrar mas eu entrei em
diversas vezes a unidade de cuidados
intensivos dos muitos hospitais do país
tive dois meses 24 sobre 24 horas de o
hospital do país no pico da pandemia
entrei em cemitérios onde a terra que é
cavada para se poupar para fazerem as
culturas escasseava não havia espaço nos
cemitérios em algumas zonas do país que
tal não era a quantidade de pessoas que
estavam morrer naquela atua com 19 no
país entrei em Laje de idosos onde as
pessoas os idosos que lá Estavam estavam
privados de ver as suas famílias durante
meses e que choravam e que me
perguntavam como é que estão os meus
netos como é que estão os meus filhos e
entrei também em mortes a completamente
lotadas de cadáveres entrei em em
capelas do hospitais que foram
utilizadas como mortes porque já não
havia a capacidade nos hospitais para
albergar tantas tantas pessoas que
estavam ser vítimas da cop-19 aqui são a
parte desta fotografia
a reportagem fixe no Santa Maria e que
foi quase dois meses de reportagem e
aqui vemos a chamada uma última chamada
este homem foi entubado nos cuidados
intensivos e ele primitivo seja feita
uma última chamada Aos familiares aqui é
exatamente um esse momento em que isso
homem faz uma vídeo chamada com a mulher
é sua mãe minutos depois foi entubado
para os cuidados intensivos
e está aqui aquilo que falava da Capela
do hospital que foi completamente
cheia esteve completamente cheia de
cadáveres vítimas de couve 19 porque não
havia espaço os hospitais não estavam
com capacidade nenhuma para albergar a
quantidade de pessoas que estavam verem
Janeiro e em fevereiro vítimas desta
doença aqui os contentores que foram
comprados por muitos hospitais no
entanto
eu uma grande uma investigação eu e mais
dois colegas que fizemos entramos dentro
de muitos contentores destes para ver em
que condições é que estas pessoas
que haviam morrido de couve 19 estavam a
ser a cuidadas e vemos Viemos com muitos
desses contentores não tinham marcas
suficientes e os cadáveres estavam ser
postos no chão sem luz aqui nesta
fotografia vemos um agente funerário com
a luz do telemóvel a procura da etiqueta
do nome onde estavam nome para saber se
se a pessoa era era era era a pessoa que
teriam que levar ou não
e estas esta esta apesar de ser um miúdo
tenho 26 anos já tive a sorte de
descobrir reportar fazer o postagens na
Síria no Iraque e em outras zonas outras
desgraças tragédias em Portugal os
incêndios de pedrógão e nunca
eu
nunca
nunca esta guerra que eu vi tanto na
Síria no Iraque na linha de frente foi
foi comparável com o que eu assisti no
último ano e meio em hospitais e outro
outros sítios onde estive a cobrir a
pandemia porque uma coisa é certa quando
nós ouvimos a professores de sírios
iraquianos porque perderam suas casas e
os familiares
de espécies culpa a expressão eles gemem
de dor eles gritam eles choram em árabe
em francês ou em inglês e aqui eu
assistia médicos a chorar em chorar e as
mer e a gritar de desespero em português
na linha na língua onde eu onde eu que a
linha a língua que eu falo e que aprendi
a falar e isso houve uma de trás
consequências não só psicológicas
Profissionais de Saúde são os maiores
heróis que eu conheci a Oi Tati não vem
toda a minha vida
mas
[Música]
eu vi uma frase que eu queria que eu
queria que eu queria aqui dizer tudo
aqui muito rápido a uma imagem aérea do
cemitério que falava de
da área térrea que estava a escassear
este talhão de terra demoraria meio ano
será ocupado este olhão Terra Demorou 15
dias estar como está 15 dias morava meio
ano estar como está todas essas pessoas
estão aqui as campas fechadas e as
tampas abertas são todas as pessoas
vítimas de convívio na grande Lisboa
a ir à a uma frase de uma médica
que me foi dito o meu lado
sobre este homem que vamos ver agora
este homem deu entrada no Santa Maria
Nas urgências
e a médica eu estar Isto foi o cerca das
quatro horas da manhã esta fotografia e
a médica
disse que ao meu lado completamente
lavado em lágrimas a máscara
completamente ensopada em lágrimas diz
que és também tem uma hora de vida e a
única coisa que eu que eles nos colegas
vamos fazer é tentar dar uma morte digna
Estas pessoas a este homem teve uma
morte digna a
apesar de tudo está sozinho foi feito
tudo o que for possível para salvar a
sua mãe e
foi posto ali porque não havia espaço no
outro Sítio do hospital para o por e
morreu ali e
com todos os tratamentos possíveis para
para para tentar aquele não mereço mas
e acabou por falecer e eu queria a pouco
a pouco Falei e repetiu muitas muitas
muitas vezes a palavra entrei entrei e
vi e fotografei e eu não quero que este
12 minutos que vocês estão aqui olha
para mim isto eu estou olhar para vocês
não quero te encarem isto com uma
promoção gratuita do meu trabalho eu
quero que te dizem esses doze minutos
para não para não se esquecerem que esta
para mim ainda não acabou a destruiu
muitas vidas e que até o dia de hoje
matou mais de sete mil pessoas obrigado
[Aplausos]
E aí